que des vies ni qui possède deux
établissements paris avec une terrasse
et l'autre sens bonsoir david ni merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors on vous imagine ans en plein
préparatif c'est le grand jour celui que
vous attendiez tant demain où il ya un
petit peu de stress parce que eh bien ma
foi c'est compliqué à mettre en oeuvre
tout ça c'est une situation assez
inédite et pour être hyper honnête
moi j'ai deux tables en terrasse dans un
de mes restaurants et dans l'autre j'ai
pas vraiment de terrasses donc je vais
je vais pas foncer la tête baissée je
vais y aller avec prudence dans le sens
où il ya quand même une crise sanitaire
qui est toujours en cours et j'ai pas
envie de risquer la centaine d habituer
juste pour récupérer quelques tables en
terrasse
donc là on est en train de regarder la
mairie a mis en place un dispositif la
mairie de paris je précise ami andy en
place un dispositif qui permet aux
restaurateurs commerçants de récupérer
un petit peu des bouts de trottoirs ou
de places de stationnement et là on est
en train de voir et je je suis plutôt
précautionneux donc je vais y aller
assez doucement dans la semaine je vais
regarder tirer une table d'une deuxième
mais toujours en gardant à l'esprit la
sécurité de mes habitués alors c'est
vrai qu'il faut préciser pour nos
téléspectateurs que la maire de paris a
donné son accord pour une extension
gratuite des terrasses notamment sur des
places de livraison 3 place apparemment
de stationnement pour augmenter votre
terrasse comment vous sentez les choses
où on a compris vous étiez de prudent
mais c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à
s'imaginer notamment pour le voisinage
voilà ça risque peut-être de créer un
joyeux désordre on va dire dans la
capitale ouais je pense que ça va être
un petit gars le risque que ça soit un
peu la fête de la musique pendant deux
semaines où je pense que tout le monde
est un peu traiter le problème à sa
sauce je pense à des collègues qui ont
déjà commencé à mettre des tables
partout et et je pense que il faut
repenser bon on réinvente un petit peu
la façon de vivre ensemble et il ya des
nouvelles règles il ya des règles
sanitaires et puis est aussi plein de
gens comme vous l'avez du lot dans le
documentaire qui s'inquiète aussi de la
santé financière de leur établissement
j'en fais partie et donc il faut réussir
à concilier tout ça c'est de prudent
mais c'est vrai je pense qu'en deux
semaines ça va être un petit peu c'est
trash arrive arrive justement parlons-en
de la rentabilité parce que c'est pas
facile d'être rentable quand on doit
mettre un mètre entre les tables quand
on vous demande parce que ce qu'il
faudrait appeler de fermer à 22 heures à
paris
est ce qu'on imagine qu'il ya plusieurs
restaurants bars qui vont préférer
rester fermés parfois de rentabilité ou
vous espérez quand même rentrer dans vos
frais avec ces restrictions très
importantes
je pense que c'est vraiment au cas par
cas moi personnellement c'est pour ça
que je préfère pas foncer la rentabilité
pas vraiment au rendez vous en ce moment
je crois que tous les parisiens qui sont
des consignes et ont envie de grand air
ont passé des moments ensemble ont pas
envie de se limiter à avoir une mètres
de distance donc on voit beaucoup de
gens sur le canal sur l'île saint louis
dont et en plus avec la réouverture des
parcs je pense qu'il y aura beaucoup de
pique nique et c'est compréhensible et
je pense que suivant les cas ceux qui
ont des grosses terrasse qui ont une
grande une grande clientèle d'habitués
il
réussir à retrouver cette clientèle
petit à petit maintenant faut voir
comment ça va se mettre en place
est ce que tout le monde a joué le jeu
est ce que au début ils vont jouer le
jeu puis après non je pense qu'il faut
il faut garder à l'esprit qu'il ya quand
même une épidémie à combattre avant tout
et il faut y aller avec précaution alors
la maire des 9e delphine bürkli estime
que les choses sont fait un petit peu
dans la précipitation quelle est votre
opinion sur ce point j'ai pas si on peut
dire précipitations dans le sens où si
on m'avait dit 2020 on va voir on va
finir sur des gains on va commencer sur
des grèves et ensuite on a enchaîné avec
eux une épidémie une épidémie mondiale
je pense que je je je
j'aurais reekoye c'est c'est un peu un
scénario hollywoodien
je crois qu'à passer c'est difficile
aujourd'hui d'avoir un manuel de bonne
conduite serre que tout le monde à un
milliard de deux scénarios à équilibrer
on voit aux états unis ils ont choisi de
favoriser l'économie sur la santé des
gens et on voit le résultat est ici on a
de la chance parce que ne rien on a
quand même un gouvernement qui a mis en
place le chômage partiel on a pas d un
peu de solidarité qui se crée en tout
cas dans les corps de métier et on
essaie de faire entendre nos droits les
bailleurs sont assez flexibles même si
effectivement un jour faudra les payer
y'a pas un guide je pense que c'est dur
aujourd'hui de de dire s'est précipité
au cédant possibilités c'est une
situation inédite et après ça chacun
d'eux d'essayer de faire au mieux je
pense clairement est ce que vous espérez
le 22 juin que ces restrictions se lève
qu'est ce qu'on vit dans votre métier
quels sont vos attentes vos espoirs
je pense que là ce qui est le ressenti
dans les métiers c'est effectivement
tous ceux qui ont des restaurants sans
terrasse comme moi on attend le 22 juin
on attend de pouvoir refaire notre
métier de pouvoir ré accueillir des gens
de pouvoir leur présenter une expérience
l'impression que j'ai en baladant à
paris en allant en allant travailler
c'est que
la plupart des gens négligent un petit
peu le l'épidémie j'ai l'impression
qu'on fait plus trop trop attention donc
encore une fois prendre avec des
pincettes et je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
d'attentes
on est tous très très impatient de
revenir au travail
c'est surtout passé de 60 70 heures par
semaine
rien c'est pas négligeable quoi ça ne
vous fait pas peur de faire un petit peu
le gendarme parce qu'on rappelle qu'il
faudra un masque quand quelqu'un se lève
pour aller aux toilettes par exemple de
satam il faudra qu'il porte un masque de
vous mettre dans la position du gendarme
c'est difficile engager votre
responsabilité
je pense ça dans le sens où à la fin
c'est la santé de mes clients qui monte
qui m'importe
et c'est un peu le papa est le papa et
les enfants kouassi si fort à payer aux
enfants de ce taux ne pas mettre les
mains dans la flamme je le ferai parce
que j'ai une responsabilité envers mon
staff envers les clients qui viennent
manger la même façon que je respecte
toutes les consignes sanitaires pour
leur servir les meilleurs plats les
mercredis sion possible j'ai aussi envie
que les gens qui viennent au restaurant
se sentent à l'aise et que l'on ne
puisse revoir des nouvelles saisons de
normalité on va dire qu'on puisse voir
un retour à la normale ensemble et si
pour ça faut que pendant deux semaines
on leur demande de mettre un masque
pendant deux semaines on leur demande de
patienter un peu plus loin de prendre
des distances
on fera en tout cas on vous souhaite le
meilleur ainsi qu'aux autres
restaurateurs bon courage pour
l'ouverture demain des vies ni d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france